الى كوسوفو حيث عززت قوات حفظ السلام التي
يقودها النيت مواقعها بحواجز جديده في
محيط مبنى بلديه سفيتشان في ظل استمرار
توافد المحتجين الصرب من جهته اعتبر
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر فوتشيتش ان
الانسحاب العاجل لمن سماهم رؤساء البلديات
المزيفين وافراد قوات الشرطه الخاصه في
عاصمه كوسوفو هو شرط للحفاظ على السلام
ونتابع جديد هذه التطورات من ميتروفيتسا
شماليه كوسوفو مع مراسلنا محمد المدهون
محمد ما الذي غير كذلك معنا احمد
الذي ينضم الينا ايضا من بلغراد وابدا معك
محمد المدهون بعد تعزيز قوات حفظ السلام
لمواقعها اذا ما الذي تغير في الموقف
مع مريم الموقف ما زال متوترا هنا على
الارض هناك المزيد من الاحتجاجات لكنها
بوتيره اقل مقارنه باليومين الماضيين يومي
الاثنين والجمعه من الاسبوع الماضي وحقيقه
هناك خبر مهم صدر قبل قليل عن حلف شمال
الاطلسي الذي اعلن انه سيرسل كتيبه
احتياطيه من القوات العمليه الاحتياطيه
لغرب البلقان هنا الى كوسوفو لزياده
وتعزيز قوات هذا بخلاف التعزيز الموجود في
البلديات الاربع المتعلق
هذه البلديات والتوتر القائم بشانها
والرفض لرؤساء البلديات الجدد هناك الحديث
عن كتيبه احتياطيه وعن وضع كتيبه اخرى في
وضع الاستعداد ربما لنشر اخر وتقليص المده
اللازمه لتجهيزها من 14 يوما الى اسبوع
واحد فقط هذا التطور المهم لابد انه سيؤخذ
في عين الاعتبار من كل الاطراف المعنيه
وهناك ايضا تحركات سياسيه جوزيف بوريل
المسؤول عن السياسه الخارجيه والامن في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا ارسل نائبه اعلن عن
ارسال نائبه قبل قليل الى كوسوفو لاجراء
مباحثات مع المسؤولين ومعرفه ما يمكن
تقديمه لتخفيف التوتر ونزع فتيل التوتر
هذا تحديدا من قبل شرطه كوسوفو التي كان
دعاها في تصريح سابق الى سحب قواتها من
محيط البلديات بما يخفف التوتر وبما يدفع
ايضا
اولئك الناشطين الذين يستخدمون وسائل
عنيفه للانسحاب من تلك الاماكن
واخلائها بما يهدئ الاوضاع
ويتيح لهؤلاء الرؤساء الجدد المنتخبين
للبلديات بالعمل من اماكن اخرى
حقيقه نحن هنا في متروفيتساء الشماليه
الوضعيه يبدو هادئا في هذه البلديه وهي
احدى البلديات التي تعد بؤرا للتوتر
البلديات الاربعه لكن على وجه التحديد هذه
البلديه الوضع يبدو هذه العربه هي الكتيبه
الايطاليه في قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها
حلف شمال الاطلسي والتي تلقت الكثير من
الضربات امس عندما اصيب نحو 30 جنديا من
الكتيبه الايطاليه وكذلك الكتيبه المجريه
ممن كانوا يحرسون بلديه زويتشان المقر
هناك وهذا المقر ما زال حقيقه مسرحا
لمواجهات كثيره وقد اصيب قبل قليل ايضا
صحفيان اخران هناك الكثير من الاعتداءات
على الصحفيين ليس فقط قوات حلف شمال
الاطلسي او شرطه ايضا صحفيين ومدنيين
تعرضوا للاعتداءات وهذه كله ياتي في سياق
المحاولات والضغوط من الجهتين
لدفع كل الطرف الاخر للتراجع عن الخطوات
الاخيره شكرا جزيلا لك محمد المدهون من
متروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو في بيل جراد احمد
بيجيتش كيف يتابع ما يجري في شمال كوسوفو
والى اي مدى يطمئن تعزيز قوات حفظ السلام
لمواقعها
في هذه المرحله
عموما موقف بالغراده لم يتغير منذ ان
دلائل الازمه الاخيره في شمال الكوسوفو
قوات صربيه او السلطات صارمه على ضروره
الانسحاب قوات الشرطه الكوسفيه من بلديات
اداه اغربيه
وايضا ليس فقط انسحاب الشرطه بل ايضا
الغاء النتائج كما يسمونهما انتخابات غير
قانونيه بانها اجريت بانها اجريت في نهايه
شهر الماضي
بمقاطعه واسعه من قبل اغلبيه صربيه وتم
اختيار السلطات الجديده
باصوات
من سكان المحليين هناك ساحه سياسيه هنا في
بالاغراض مليئه بالاحداث وبدا اليوم بلقاء
الرئيس الصربي الكسنش مع ممثلين
واديبلوماسيين من خمس دول الكبرى في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بريطانيا
وايطاليا
والمانيا وفرنسا
مشدده الرئيس الصربي خلال اللقاء اليوم
شدد على ضروره التزام السلطات الكوسوفيه
باتفاقيات المبرمه بين بريستينا وبلغراد
وعلى ضروره سحب قواتها من بلديات ذاتها
اغلبيه
وكان هناك ايضا اجتماع اليوم رئيس
صربيا ممثلين دبلوماسيين وسفراء كل من
الصين وروسيا
وشدد في رحب بموقف روسيا وصين تجاه الازمه
الاخيره وسفيره الصينيه في بلغراده صرحت
بان بلادها تدعم وحده اراضي صربيا وتدعم
سياده السربي على كل شبر من اراضيها كما
شدد الرئيس كبر شدد سفير الروسي على على
موقفي مع قوات صربيا في اي لحظه وسلطات
الصربيه ودعم كبير من قبل كرملين لسلطات
صربيا نحو كوسوفا وتطورات هناك شكرا لك
احمد بيتشيتش من برجراف